oh um question 11 um now just full
disclosure okay this question is
confusing because it's a corny geometry
question and so we're used to thinking
about life you know air going into a
balloon or water going into a trough or
whatever physical things which I think
make it quite easy to visualize and
think about okay I know what formulas i
have to do here in or a different [ __ ]
this is corner geometry which you would
think we're very familiar with but when
you may come that's that's okay when you
think about related rates it really is
anything that's changing you have
different quantities okay so because I
think this is quite confusing the method
I'm going to show you it's actually a
little convoluted so I'm um I'm not at
all confident that it's the best way to
do it so if you as I'm going through
this you're like hey why are we doing
that's a long way around then please let
me know at the end because as we've seen
before with these questions is often
many many different ways to do it right
like I think one question we did like
three or four different ways right so if
you have some flash of insight in the
middle of me explain this then please
share it but otherwise we will try and
explain crush 11 sir a point moves
clockwise around the circle x squared
plus y squared equals 1 so in cycle pull
it up
ah it started off well and then it died
anyway okay um unit circle so we've got
you know 11 take a [ __ ] um and there's a
point moving anti clockwise around it at
a uniform speed up two meters second
because you know as you do okay so let's
put a point on here and it's moving
around in an anti-clockwise direction
two meters per second that's the rain
and later on they tell us that the units
of the axes are meters okay all right so
the question is find an expression for
the rate of change of its x-coordinate
in terms of X when the point is above
the x axis hmm ok so there's not there's
a lot of hair let's try and piece it
together okay number one find an
expression for the rate of change of its
x-coordinate so what are we after its
supposed time rate of change of the
x-coordinate DX on the team right okay
as in this point it's got a position
around there and we're just thinking
about the X the horizontal position I
want to see how should you have time ok
good now we want to find what this is in
terms of X when the point is above the x
axis I've already drawn fear so that's
fine okay so we're going to get equals
some function right and we want
everything over here to be X's and no
otherwise or teaser that ok now where do
you start when you go with this well
usually we say you know you've got some
rate and then there are other rates
which you know which you've got to get
it in terms of ok so i've got this point
and it's moving so the question is what
is on what's the great barbecue that's
that's changing hmm so this there's the
exit is Wireless changing but this thing
is not moving according to X or Y per se
right what shape is Olivia that's within
a circle right William the arc yeah so
therefore what kind of a metric am I
going to pull on here which has a rate
of change okay well what I'm going to do
is put onto their whoops a an arc length
right and that's the thing that's
getting longer and shorter because it's
to me to the second is going round and
round and run around right so I need a
starting point and on the question is
said above the axis right so I'm just
going to say let's just start there the
question doesn't tell us where we start
so i take it that move it's not really
that significant okay and it's going up
and it's increasing okay so if i start
here hmm what kind of shape in my dude
getting arc right so what should we call
this what you recall this distance here
he suggestions a couple of eggs that's
no taken in takers now yeah i'm gonna go
with l I think L is good because it's an
arc flick but I want me to do a Radian
measure we said it's l equals R theta so
I'll go an arc l and it's growing over
time I in fact it's going at this rate
so dl entity is too okay so let's just
keep that fire going okay now therefore
how is this thing changing as it moves
across hmm this is the tricky part okay
let's think about what position am I in
at any given time so for instance this
thing has coordinates right now I could
call it X Y but that won't be very
helpful would it it doesn't give me any
extra information matter we know though
that this is a very specific kind of
circle right this is the unit circle so
what are the coordinates yes y corners
never remember ah good so are so it's
going to be these are treat functions
I'm so the chief hunter is often called
circular functions because they pee
really go run around around right so
it'll be our cos theta R sine theta
where R is the radius radius here's one
right so this is just going to be in cos
theta sine theta does that make sense
this is my coordinate so for instance
after time say one second okay one
second passes so I've moved two meters
around of the circle okay now i just
said looks like we start here how far
have I actually got what position will I
be in this is the unit circle and so
what's the circumference of the insert
so conference is 2 PI R and R is 1 so
the whole thing is 2 pi 6.28 their bouts
okay so different from here to here half
the circumference is pi 3.14 so after
one second i'm expecting to be about
two-thirds the way around yes so say
something like that okay so i might say
T equals 1 this is where I am okay the
arc L that I've traced out right that
length will be two meters right because
that's the rec time travel again so
therefore what I'm trying to get after
is what are my coordinates at this point
okay how do I work out the coordinates
if I know the length of this arc I've
made is true how do I get
good exactly right I can get my position
up here based on this angle here right
if my quarters are costly to sign theta
then up here now that's our feet r is
equal to two and my radius is just what
right so in fact it just means theta is
equal to 2 radians so I can check on
okay so this particular point that I was
interested in if theta is equal to its
coordinates will be caused to scientific
whatever is under all right now let's
consider another example I'm trying to
get at how is X moving okay I don't want
to go another second like two seconds
because then I'd come all the way back
down here and I'm just interested in the
top off okay so let's think about saying
half a second when t is equal to a half
where am I going to me when is somewhere
up here right okay now follow the same
logic if the length of my Arc was equal
to 2 in this case what's like the young
you yeah just we want right and we saw
that was equal to theta because the
radius equal one man so this point what
my coordinates bear if there is one
radium it's going to be close one sign
one
okay so here's what I'm after I'm trying
to get what's X equal to as it changes
over time when t is a half x was cause
one to Mayor Royce pool table
when he was one second it was caused to
you can imagine if i did go two seconds
what would the export of it maybe cause
form right what's the kind of pattern
that I'll observing how would I explain
you know if I was at time just generally
speaking time T what kind of pattern can
i see well whatever this thing is is
always double the time right so it's
going to be close x Donald sign up times
cause of double the time you see that
you see how I formed that happen okay
now why is this useful because if x
equals cos 2t now I can start working
toward dx1 ET because I can
differentiate this what's the derivative
it's an easy one you do get minus coz
the pods goes into minus side and then
you do chain rule so there's the inside
and then terms of design okay so this is
good at least so far been to progress
dat is that but of course the question
is Jeff and it scares give me the rate
of change of the x coordinate give me DX
LBT in terms of X so I'm in terms of tea
at the moment what am I going to do how
can I twist and squeeze this thing so
it's in terms of X how do you do it how
did you go about it
I've got science somehow I've got to
squeeze them into cosines okay what's
the easiest relationship you know that
lets me interchange between science and
cosines any tankers comes from comes
from the unit circle it'll be the I
think I've heard it may be the
Pythagorean relationship right which is
that Khan squared plus sine squared is
one right so you're this close skype a
science-based evil one
this is true for any angle right it can
be our fire it can be gamma can be two
teen if you like so let's put two T's in
places that's what I'm actually dealing
with all right so I've got coz square 2
T sine square sweetie that's equal to
one so far so good now these guys here I
can immediately replace because I know
what cause 2 T is its X right so I'm
I've got cos squared so I'm like x
squared here evening what about here
sine squared 2 t is equal to 1 I now
want to sort of beside this so i can get
towards the X on the team okay how do I
do it well let's make it a subject
that's first on science square 2 T is 1
minus x squared I've got it squared but
my derivative is not squared so I'll
needs then the square root of both sides
so I'll have slam to t equal to the
square root of now by the way is it plus
or minus plus plus or minus
hey there you keep thank you for the
room it is plus it's not as obvious as
you might think they're okay it's class
now it does have to do with it being the
top half the circle but okay keep going
cited here I want minus 2 sine 2t so
I'll start on minus 2 on both side and
this is the xle team
it's a tile done okay now at the top
question at least was for me like i said
i was a little convoluted right because
you had to there are numerous number of
insights in there which they didn't
expect you they didn't give to you you
had to do so get on your own like what
our relationships between x and y is
Theta business and even really around
its in its Radian measure right that's
hard and then going from here to here
sorry from heating up was also tricky
because the relationship between is not
immediately obvious okay I just around
it up there's a puppy I think to a
question use your answer to Part A to
find the rate of change of the x
coordinate as it crosses the y axis as
crosses the y-axis so in this case x is
equal to zero so let's just plug it in
when x equals y DX on dt is equal to all
right what I got here minus 2 times the
square root of 1 which is minus 2 now
the question very helpfully I it's like
mocking us says why should this adds a
bit obvious without this formula you
tell me why does that actually jump out
without doing all of this renewal
ahh ok good right so what's going on all
the way around the circle except at four
specific points all the way around we're
moving both up and down and across ways
right because we're moving around the
circle but there are four points where
we're not going in both directions he
are for instance we're going straight up
because if I'd your tangent anybody and
here we're going straight to the right
because I'm going anti-clockwise
therefore of PR the tangent again will
be horizontal so I'm going straight
across that's what the negative is about
right because I'm going from right to
left ok so actually at this particular
point we could have read that result
straight off the graph